welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host paul aka the guy who was
voted most likely to be a time traveler
in the class of 2099.
are you having that now loki episode 1
introduces some of marvel's most
powerful characters into the mcu
the tva are the kind of people that use
the power stone as a paperweight
and in this video we're going to be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about them
this includes who the organization are
as a whole what's going on with the
timekeepers
and our theory on why kang the conqueror
could be behind it all
bold spoilers ahead so if you haven't
had time on your hands to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now
if you enjoy the video then please smash
the thumbs up button
and make sure you subscribe or i'll gut
you like a fish
what's a fish now without the way thanks
for the click
let's get into the video okay so i think
before talking about the tva
we have to talk about the timekeepers as
they're basically what the entire
organization is built around
now the thing that you have to
understand about the marvel universe
is that it's very much cyclical and when
it dies it respawns the next phase
which starts again with some slight
variations on what came before
upon its ending the universe goes into
what's called a heat death
and from this something new is created
in the comics the timekeepers were
created by he who remains
who was the last surviving member of the
tva from the previous universal cycle
it's very much a chicken in the egg
situation in which we don't really know
what came first
and he who remains created the
timekeepers in order to avoid the
mistakes of the past
interestingly the first attempt to make
them resulted in the time twisters
which just so happens to be the name of
a device in the show
he who remains didn't want the previous
issues from the prior universe to
develop once more
and thus he made the timekeepers to
protect not only the timeline
but time itself now there were actually
four created
but one was exiled to egypt which we'll
talk about later on
their main jobs were to unravel any
issues caused by time travel
and thus they founded the tva who would
follow their orders in order to keep
things on this straight and narrow
they've gone head to head with the
avengers several times and upon the
emergence of scarlet witch
they quickly identified her as a nexus
being now they've also worked alongside
a mortise
who you might also know as nathaniel
richards aka kang the conqueror
they sent him out to stop skull at witch
from having children
but as with most time travel shenanigans
he ended up causing events that led to
her relationship with vision
now in case you don't know who kang the
conqueror is he's likely
going to be the next big bad in the mcu
and jonathan mages has been cast as the
villain in the upcoming ant-man movie
quantum mania ravana ren slayer also
features in the show as a judge
and she was very much the object of
kang's affections
thus it is possible that he could be
popping up now the timekeepers in kang
are very much mortal enemies
and due to the antagonists constantly
using time travel to achieve his goals
they've often hired the tva and helped
heroes from behind the scenes in order
to defeat him
now because we don't really see the
timekeepers in the show i actually think
that they might not exist anymore
and that it could be kang controlling
the events that we see play out in the
series
i would love it if the fourth time
keeper that was exiled was somewhat
changed in the show to actually be
nathaniel
and we could learn that he had
overthrown the three in order to alter
time for his own ends
something just seems off with the tva
and the way that they're worshipped as
deities
it just makes no god damn sense now
interestingly in the comics the time
twisters
actually came back and pretended to be
the time keepers they sent immortus out
to absorb the energy of skull at which
and shortly after he started working
against them
since then they've used their powers to
control events to the best of their
abilities
and though it is possible to escape
their grasp and defeat them
the majority of the marvel universe is
the way that they wished it to be
now their main tool is the tva or rather
the time variance authority not only are
they the monitors of the timeline
they're also judge jury and executioner
when deciding what timelines are allowed
to exist
using their temporal charges they can
pretty much prune an entire branch
reality from existence
and very much decide the flow of history
though we don't see time travel in the
mcu until the events of avengers end
game
in marvel comics it actually pops up far
more than you might think
lots of people go back and change time
and whether events are drastically
altered or not
the butterfly effect often creates new
variants which the tva
are always there to clean up now they
first showed up in thor 327
and through justice piece we sort of got
a hint towards how they operated
this storyline which spanned the
aforementioned entry and the following
one
merely introduced them and it wasn't
until 353 of the fantastic four
that we learned more about them here
they arrested marvel's first family for
crimes against time travel
and we discovered their headquarters in
an old time zone the man put in charge
of the fantastic four case was mobius
and mobius
who is of course played by owen wilson
in the show now the fantastic four
managed to escape
and several tva files were lost during
this
mobius was nearly demoted and he
attempted to capture the fantastic four
once more in order to right the wrongs
of his own past
throughout the comics he's worked
alongside the kang dynasty in
kronanopolis which depending on what fan
theories you read
may have been a miniature city that
could be spotted in the quantum realm
in ant-man and the wasp mobius has
remained somewhat a mysterious figure
and we haven't really had an origin
story for him yet
he has however made his presence felt in
the comics and he did appear during
she-hulk's trial
when she was charged with attempting to
warn a past version of hawkeye of his
inevitable death
now though he tends not to get his own
hands dirty in the source material
the show seems to be something that's
going to have him more on site than his
comic book counterpart
i have seen episode 2 of the show
already as i got early access to the
first two from disney
i know i don't want to spoil anything he
does have a way more active role in that
than what i've ever really seen in the
comics it's clear he wants to stop this
variant of loki no matter what
and he's gonna be a great sidekick to
the main man
now with him taking a bit more of a back
seat in the comics he tends to use the
time cops that the tva have
or the chrono monitors as they're called
in the marvel universe
the mcu has changed them up slightly to
be called the minutemen
and this is likely because ms minutes
seems to be someone quite high up in the
organization
though she initially seems just like the
face or mascot of the group
we can see in the elevator shots that
there is a flaw that leads directly to
her
so she may be an actual living entity or
if we're wrong about kang
perhaps she is one of the time keepers
now as for the minutemen
the show has them possessing far more
personality than they do in the comics
in those they're pretty much faceless
individuals that are created through
quantum technology
they don't really have a life certainly
don't know what a fish is and only
spring into existence at the offshoot of
a new reality
these work all hours of the day and you
could say they're working
overtime hey you're having that now
every reality comes with them
as they exist within the main timeline
when a branch reality is born
they come along with it much in the same
way that everything from the main
timeline does
so they're always there to stand guard
when a new offshoot is made
it's a lot to get your head around and i
think the show is going more with the
idea that these are just
agents who are assigned to bring in
temporal offenders so that they can be
seen by a judge
now what do they say to the clock when
it's time's up
hands hands up like like hands on a
clock
now though they pretty much hold the
entire power of the universe in their
hands
they're not all powerful and their
abilities are limited to things like
human error
and the constant bureaucracy that they
have to deal with
managing all the events that they have
to throughout time and the paperwork
that goes with it
is very time consuming and though they
will most likely get round to fixing
almost every problem
some do slip through the net the ending
of the first episode has also shown that
it is possible to evade them too
and strike at them when they least
expect it in the final scene we catch a
mysterious variant of loki
waiting until they're investigating an
oil dig carried out by a time traveler
and here they strike
this variant has also managed to evade
their capture and this shows that
they're not all powerful
and the next episode does unravel a lot
of the mystery surrounding who this
is but until then i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories on the tva
as a thank you for commenting on the
video you'll be entered into a prize
draw on the 30th of june
in which we're giving away three copies
of the mcu phase three box set
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the
video
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the first episode itself
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over the full plot and
pointed out most of the easter eggs
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else after this
without the way thank you for saying
through the video i've been poor i'll
see you next time
take care peace